houston mega church pastor joel olsteen
is responding this morning to criticism
of his response to harvey's flooding
he initially did not open the lakewood
church which can seat at least 16
000 to evacuees lakewood church posted
on facebook sunday saying this
it was inaccessible due to severe
flooding the post received backlash on
social media when photos were posted
that seemed to contradict those claims
osteen
tweeted on yesterday lakewood's doors
are open and we are receiving anyone who
needs
shelter now joel osteen joins us from
houston's lakewood church
this morning hello joel steen hey gail
good to hear from you well it looks like
things are up and running and not to
make light of it but some people say
pastor you've got some splaining to do
because from sunday there was one
message from facebook
and then it appeared that the doors were
not open to anyone
how do you explain the discrepancies
well you know gales our doors have
always been open
we received people even as soon as the
water started receiving
but we worked with the city constantly
the city
set up a shelter about four miles from
here that can house ten thousand people
showers dormitories kitchen security all
that they didn't need us as a shelter at
that point they wanted us to be a
distribution center things like that so
we said fine you do that we'll do our
part never dreaming that we have so many
people needing shelters when they filled
up
they said we need shelters we started
our shelter but you know
this this notion that we would turn
people away or that we're not here for
the city
we've been here for 60 years doing this
tropical storm
i don't think anybody thought that you
turned anybody away i think they think
that the church was not open and that
the words were that it was closed due to
severe flooding and the video evidence
seemed to show listen there was no
flooding at the church why wasn't it not
open immediately i think is the bottom
line
none of that is true there was flooding
if we didn't have our floodgates out
back here it was within one foot
this building flooded in 2001 the whole
bottom floor
this was it would have been a safety
concern at the start but that's really
not the bigger issue is that the issue
is we work with the city they said let
us be the shelter they said go to the
county go to the city shelter so
you know somebody created a notion that
you know what we're not open in time but
they're not sitting here seeing that
the mayor's saying don't stay on the
streets don't get on the streets
that this building is a safety issue
we're here to help people we've been
doing this for 60 years so
you know that's what we're all about
here at lakewood helping the city it was
tuesday before you got really up and
running
why did it take so long to mobilize
it's if you were here you would
understand why we our volunteers people
that run this building
they can't get they can't get to the
facility we couldn't even set up our tv
hardly today
from some of our crew so you know you
just have to be here to see that
number one the city runs the shelters
what they need us to do they ask for a
distribution center and you see
hundreds and thousands of volunteers
came out they need a command center hey
you can do it here at lakewood
if you need a shelter we could have been
a shelter from day one if they wanted
that how many people have you taken in
so far
yeah i don't know how many i've lost
count but there i know there are
hundreds and
yesterday we had you know people
bringing supplies and just
you know we can't even we can hardly
take any more supplies here but
we continue to take people as many as
they bring pastor how many
can you take in and i see on your
website that you've already begun
fundraising to help the victims but
it's not clear what charity that's going
to or how it's going to be used
who are you raising money for well we'd
be
raising money for the victims here in
houston i don't know how it all works
we're working with
samaritan's purse and different ones but
we're going to be here
five years from now helping these people
we've been here for many years doing
that
so it will go to the people that are
affected by the flooding many of us many
of them are own members
are you concerned that it might be
harmful to your congregation that
there's this perception that
your church was not a sanctuary that
that even came into question in the
first place
not one bit i never paid attention to
twitter it never came up we know who we
are
if you let social media run your life in
your ministry you'll never do anything
everybody has critics that's making a
difference we know we did the right
thing for safety working with the city
and
you know that's why thousands of people
are coming out and responding now all
right pastor you've got a lot going on
behind you what is that behind you help
us
understand what is that uh we the city
asked us to be a distribution center so
people are bringing baby foods and baby
supplies and medical supplies and things
like that so
we're taking in supplies that we can
feed the different shelters around town
and so that's what they've asked us to
do and we're doing that along it's
sheltering the people here thank you
pastor for joining us
and the doors of lakewood church are
open
thanks so much gail great talking with
you all all right good to see you